Welcome back to the ledger. To master
insurance operations, you have to speak
the exact language of underwriters.
Let's start by permanently clearing up
the single biggest point of confusion in
the entire industry. Risk versus peril.
Risk is defined strictly as the
fundamental uncertainty concerning a
loss. It represents the actual subject
matter of an insurance policy.
Underwriters split risk into two
categories.
Speculative risk can result in either a
gain or a loss, like buying stocks or
betting on a game, making it entirely
uninsurable.
Insurance deals exclusively with pure
risk, which can only produce a loss with
absolutely zero chance of financial
gain. We manage risk through four
distinct methods: risk avoidance, loss
prevention, and reduction. risk
retention or risk transfer via an
insurance policy. Now look at peril.
Peril is not the uncertainty itself. It
is the actual immediate cause of the
loss. The unpredictable event insured
against like a fire, an earthquake or a
shipwreck. If a peril is the cause of a
loss, what makes that loss more likely
to happen? That is a hazard. Hazards are
factors that actively increase the
chance of loss from apparel and
underwriters classify them into three
distinct buckets. First, we have
physical hazards. These are tangible,
structural, or environmental dangers
that you can physically see or touch,
such as stockpiling highly combustible
goods inside a building, leaving exposed
electrical wiring uncovered, positioning
properties in low-lying floodprone
areas, leaving an open manhole on a
walkway, or driving a vehicle with
defective signal tail lights. Second are
moral hazards. These are internal
vulnerabilities directly related to the
psychological character, integrity, or
honesty of the insured individual.
Examples include outright dishonesty, a
poor credit standing, or an alarming
history of numerous past losses. Third
are morale hazards. Notice the spelling
difference here. Morale hazards are
factors rooted entirely in a person's
negative attitude, carelessness, or deep
indifference to a loss simply because
they know they are fully covered by an
insurance policy. This looks like poor
property housekeeping or a complete lack
of basic loss prevention measures.
Let's talk money and calculations.
When an insurance policy is written, the
face amount listed on the document is
called the total sum insured or TSI.
This number represents the absolute
maximum limit of the insurer's legal
liability. To activate this liability,
the insured must pay a consideration
value called the premium. The strict
general rule of the industry dictates no
premium equals no policy and no
liability. The only legal exceptions are
explicitly documented credit terms or an
established structural grace period in
life insurance contracts. When an
insurance company totals up its premium
production over a specific period of
time, that baseline sum is called the
gross premiums written or GPW. But
taking on massive amounts of risk all
alone can cause a company to go under.
So insurers protect themselves using
reinsurance. Reinsurance is literally
defined as an insurance of an insurance.
The primary insurer shares a portion of
their total sum insured and premiums
with another professional reinsurer.
When you take the gross premiums written
and subtract that outsourced reinsurance
data, you are left with the net premiums
written or NPW. So who calls the shots
behind the scenes? The underwriter is
the operational gatekeeper whose duty is
to select, evaluate, accept risks, set
terms, and determine the exact amount of
liability the company will retain. To
operate, every underwriter must be fully
licensed by the National Insurance
Commission. When policies are sold, they
use intermediaries. An agent explicitly
represents the insurance company.
Non-life agents can represent up to
seven companies, while life agents can
represent only one. Conversely, an
insurance broker represents the client.
Brokers must be fully incorporated,
registered with the Securities and
Exchange Commission, SEC, and require a
certified soliciting official. All of
these gatekeepers use the law of large
numbers to calculate precise loss
probabilities. For a risk to even be
considered insurable, it must meet five
strict structural criteria. a large
number of homogeneous exposure units,
minimal catastrophic or simultaneous
loss probability, a highly definite and
measurable event, an economically
feasible cost, and a calculable chance
of loss. Next up in video three, we are
taking this layout straight into the
courtroom to look at insurance contract